David Boder: [In English] This is Spool Number 50. The interviewee is Dr. Jacob Wilf. Paris, August 17, 1946. Dr. Wilf is from Katowice, Poland and is now at the conference of the ORT in Paris.
David Boder: [In German] Also Herr Doktor, sagen Sie uns noch einmal was ist Ihr Name. Sie sprechen jiddisch, ja?
Jacob Wilf: Ja.
David Boder: [In German/Yiddish] Was ist Euer Namen?
Jacob Wilf: Namen: Jacob Wilf.
David Boder: Und was für ein Doktor sind Sie?
Jacob Wilf: Jurist.
David Boder: Sie sind Doktor Juri. Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Doktor?
Jacob Wilf: Ich bin vierzig Jahre
David Boder: Oh, Sie sind bloß vierzig (40) Jahre. Haben Sie als Advokat praktiziert?
Jacob Wilf: Ja, ich bin jetzt Advokat in Katowice.
David Boder: Sie sind jetzt ein Advokat in Katowice. Also, Herr Doktor, ich verstehe, dass Sie nach...in Russland gewesen sind, nicht wahr?
Jacob Wilf: Ja.
David Boder: Wurden Sie nach Russland deportiert?
Jacob Wilf: Nein, ich bin freiwillig heraus gegangen.
David Boder: Von Polen sind Sie nach Russland gegangen.
Jacob Wilf: Ja.
David Boder: Sprechen Sie ein bisschen lauter. Wohin und wann sind Sie gefahren nach Russland?
Jacob Wilf: Ich bin am Juli neunzehn hundert ein vierzig (1941) bin ich herein gekommen nach Russland.
David Boder: Die Deutschen waren noch nicht in Katowice?
Jacob Wilf: Nein, die Deutschen sind schon lang in Katowice gewesen. Ich war in einem anderen Part—in Lemberg.
David Boder: Oh, waren die Deutschen in Lemberg?
Jacob Wilf: Nein, sie waren noch nicht in Lemberg, Ich war...
David Boder: Also sie waren noch nicht in Lemberg?
Jacob Wilf: Noch nicht.
David Boder: Die Deutschen waren in Katowice bevor sie waren in Lemberg?
Jacob Wilf: Im neun und dreißiger (39) Jahr sind sie gewesen schon in Katowitz.
David Boder: Ja,...und in Lemberg waren Sie?
Jacob Wilf: Am dreißigsten (30.) Juni neunzehn hundert ein vierzig (1941).
David Boder: Wer hat Lemberg verteidigt?
Jacob Wilf: Die Polen...hm, hm, die Russen.
David Boder: Die Russen haben Lemberg verteidigt und haben genommen Lemberg später.
Jacob Wilf: Ja.
David Boder: Und Sie waren in Lemberg?
David Boder: So sind Sie von Lemberg weg gegangen nach Russland?
Jacob Wilf: Ja.
David Boder: Hm, mit die Russen zusammen oder wie war das?
Jacob Wilf: Mit den Russen zusammen, mit dem Militär.
David Boder: Mit dem Militär...
Jacob Wilf: . . . komissioniert.
David Boder: Sind viele Juden weg gegangen?
Jacob Wilf: Leider sind nur wenig gegangen.
David Boder: Leider sind nur wenig Juden weg gegangen. Was hat passiert zu diese, was sind geblieben?
Jacob Wilf: Die, die sind geblieben sind zu acht und neunzig (98) Prozent vernichtet worden in Deutschland.
David Boder: Haben Sie zufällig einen Advokaten, einen Doktor Löwenherz von Danzig gekannt?
Jacob Wilf: Nein.
David Boder: In Lwow Sie haben ihn nicht gekannt?
David Boder: Er war von Gnydia, Danzig.
Jacob Wilf: Nein.
David Boder: Also erzählen Sie mir was hat passiert, wenn Sie sind weg gegangen mit den Russen.
Jacob Wilf: Am dreißigsten (30.) Juni neunzehn hundert ein und vierzig (1941) bin ich mobilisiert worden in the Rote Armee...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Wilf: . . . und mit der Roten Armee bin ich weg, wir haben zurück gezogen.
David Boder: Wie alt waren Sie?
Jacob Wilf: Ich bin damals gewesen...vier und dreißig (34).
David Boder: Vier und dreißig (34). Was hat man Sie gemacht? Einen gewöhnlichen Soldaten?
Jacob Wilf: Einen gewöhnlichen Soldaten.
David Boder: Und Sie sind mitgegangen mit der Roten Armee...
Jacob Wilf: . . . ich bin gegangen mit der roten Armee. Und bis zum Kaukasus haben wir uns zurück gezogen.
David Boder: Ja, nun?
Jacob Wilf: Danach bin ich demobilisiert geworden, also ich bin abgestammt von Polen...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Wilf: . . . und alle die abgestammt sind von Polen sind damals demobilisiert geworden.
David Boder: Warum?
Jacob Wilf: Der Fall war, dass zu der Zeit hat man nicht gehabt das entsprechende Zutrauen zu die polnischen Bürger, dass sie einen aktiven Kampf gegen die Deutschen anfangen.
David Boder: Haben Sie gewusst, dass sei sein ein Jüd?
Jacob Wilf: Ja, das haben sie gewusst.
David Boder: Aber sie haben Sie demobilisiert.
Jacob Wilf: Ja, als Pole.
David Boder: So was haben Sie gemacht nachdem man Sie demobilisierte?
Jacob Wilf: Danach bin ich gezogen tief ins Land. Und ich bin gekommen nach Turkmenien, in die Turkmenische Republik.
David Boder: Haben Sie Familie mit sich gehabt?
Jacob Wilf: Die Frau hab ich mit genommen.
David Boder: Ihre Frau, sie haben keine Kinder?
Jacob Wilf: Nein.
David Boder: Nein. Und die Frau ist mit gegangen mit der Armee?
Jacob Wilf: Sie hat sich angeschlossen der russischen Armee...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Wilf: . . . und im Sommer, im August neunzehn hundert ein und vierzig (1941) sind wir gekommen in Turkmenien.
Jacob Wilf: Dort haben wir sich abgesetzt.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Wilf: Dort habe ich gearbeitet als Advokat.
David Boder: Haben sie gelasst Euch arbeiten als russische Advokat.
Jacob Wilf: Sie haben mich gelassen...ich habe gewisse Prüfung mitgemacht und man hat mir erlaubt als Advokat, als russischer Advokat.
David Boder: Ihr redet russisch?
Jacob Wilf: Ich red sehr gut russisch.
David Boder: Ihr redet gut russisch? Wo haben Sie studiert?
Jacob Wilf: Ich hab studiert in Krakau...
David Boder: Aha.
Jacob Wilf: . . . an der Universität.
Jacob Wilf: Im neun und zwanziger Jahr.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Wilf: Im Jahr neunzehn hundert neun und zwanzig (1929) hab ich absolviert.
David Boder: [In Russian] А где Вы научились по-русски?
Jacob Wilf: По-русски изучил я во время немецкой войны, немецко-польской войны, когда я был во Львове...
David Boder: Да.
Jacob Wilf: Я изучил русский язык.
David Boder: Вы изучали русский язык.
Jacob Wilf: Да, хорошо.
David Boder: Ну, так что Вы...
David Boder: [In German/Yiddish] So, haben praktiziert als Advokat wo?
Jacob Wilf: In Marie...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Wilf: Turkmenische Republik.
Jacob Wilf: Dort hab ich gleichzeitig, nach ein paar Monaten bin ich gewesen, habe ich vorgetragen juristische Disziplinen in der juristischen Schule.
David Boder: Ja. Eine russische juristische Schule.
Jacob Wilf: Ja. Und meine Frau hat gearbeitet auf einer grösseren Fabrik...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Wilf: . . . in der Stadt auch. Und sie war da in der Planabteilung.
Jacob Wilf: Und dort sind wir gewesen bis zum fünf und vierziger (45) Jahr und im Zusammenhang mit der Repatriation sind wir wieder zurück gekommen nach Polen.
David Boder: Haben die Russen Euch keine Schwierigkeiten gemacht zurück zu gehen?
Jacob Wilf: Nein. Ganz freiwillig, wer gewollt hat, hat die entsprechenden Dokumente, Geldhilfe und Proviant für den Weg...
David Boder: Geldhilfe und Proviant für den Weg?
Jacob Wilf: . . . und Proviant für den Weg und dann sind wir wieder gekommen nach Polen.
David Boder: So seid Ihr zurück gekommen zu wer?
Jacob Wilf: Wir sind zurück gekommen noch im Juli neunzehn hundert fünf und vierzig...
David Boder: Es war noch bevor...[unverständlich].
Jacob Wilf: Ja.
David Boder: Haben die Russen Euch mobilisiert?
Jacob Wilf: Nein...nein.
David Boder: Nein. Also hier ist die Geschichte natürlich sehr interessant was in Russland passiert, aber das ist nicht unsere Frage. Erzählen Sie mir denn, wie haben Sie vorgefunden Polen und was tut sich jetzt in Polen im Allgemeinen mit den Juden. Und erklären Sie mir die ganze Geschichte von Kielce Pogrom. Fangen Sie an mit der allgemeinen Lage. Sind Sie betätigt mit die jüdischen Sachen?
Jacob Wilf: Ja. Ich bin—in dem Moment—bin ich der Vize-Vorsitzende von dem allgemeinen Kommittee von Oberschlesien.
David Boder: Das ist was...ein allgemeine...?
Jacob Wilf: Ein allgemeines jüdisches Kommittee.
David Boder: Oh, ein allgemeines jüdisches...[beide sprechen]
Jacob Wilf: Das ist die einzige Repräsentanz der Juden in Polen...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Wilf: In dem Kommittee sind vertreten alle Parteien...
Jacob Wilf: . . . die sind tätig am heutigen Tag auf der jüdischen Gasse.
David Boder: Also sagen Sie mir, was für eine Repräsentation hat man nötig? Alle seien doch gleiche Bürger in Polen?
Jacob Wilf: Ja, die Juden haben aber spezielle Interessen, die die Kommittees müssen vertreten.
David Boder: Zum Beispiel?
Jacob Wilf: Vor allem sind die Kommittees entstanden aus den Hilfskommittees. Es hat sich darum gehandelt, wenn die Juden sind zurück gekommen von die Lager...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Wilf: . . . und dann sind noch die Repatriaten gekommen von Russland.
Jacob Wilf: und sie geben die erste nötige Hilfe. Das ist gewesen die Hauptaufgabe von den jüdischen Kommittees in Polen. Heutzutage behandeln die jüdischen Kommittees spezielle andere Fragen. Die Hauptfrage, die sie gestellt haben an das jüdische Kommittee, ist zu Produktvisieren die jüdischen Massen.
David Boder: Und wer macht das?
Jacob Wilf: In erster Reihe, die Juden, die alles durch den Krieg verloren haben, ihr Haus und Vermögen und ihre Arbeitsstätten. Die Kommittees müssen finden und geben Juden die Möglichkeit wieder aufzubauen ihre Arbeitswerkstatt.
David Boder: Das ist sehr interessant, Herr Wilf, wollen Sie reden ein bisserl langsamer, denn es ist sehr wichtig, was sie mir sagen. Nun...
Jacob Wilf: Also die Kommittees sind die einzigen Organisationen [unverständlich- polnische und jüdische Worte] die jüdischen Massen wieder produktiv arbeiten. Dass sie geben als Kommitäten materielle Hilfe ..
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Wilf: . . . weil anordnen die Juden zur Arbeit.
David Boder: Zum Beispiel welche Kommitäten?
Jacob Wilf: Die jüdischen Kommitäten jeder Stadt geben materielle Hilfe den Juden, so dass sie können wieder aufbauen ihre Werkstatt.
David Boder: Und von woher kriegen sie die Mittel?
Jacob Wilf: Die Mittel haben sie für lange Zeit—noch zurück mit [Name unverständlich]—die ausschließliche Hilfe haben sie bekommen [etliche Worte unverständlich] von der polnischen Regierung
David Boder: Von der polnischen Regierung?
Jacob Wilf: Ausschließlich von der polnischen Regierung.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Wilf: Im fünf und vierziger (45) Jahr hat der Joint noch nicht gegeben gewisse entsprechende Geldsummen für die Juden in Polen. Die einzige Hilfe in neunzehn hundert fünf und vierzig, die die jüdischen Kommitäten haben gehabt für die [unverständlich; polnisches Wort]—für die Juden, waren Produkte, die man bekommen hat von der polnischen Regierung—in Geldsummen.
Jacob Wilf: Dieses Jahr bekommen wir schon die Geldsummen von dem Joint.
David Boder: Hm.
Jacob Wilf: Auch dieses Jahr bekommen wir Produkte, die werden verteilt zwischen der jüdischen Bevölkerung.
David Boder: Aha. Nun und was tut die ORT dort?
Jacob Wilf: Ausserdem existiert in Polen die Organisation ORT, die schon geschaffen ist in die größeren Städte, in die Städte, wo eine größere jüdische Belegschaft. Sie schaffen Fachschule, sie geben speziell für die jüdische Jugend, die nicht gehabt haben die Möglichkeit ein Fach wegen der Okkupation zu lernen, sie geben das Fach in die Hand, sie geben entsprechende Bildung. Schon bei uns in [unverständlich; hebräische Worte] haben wir in Oberschlesien, wo ich der Vorsitzende von dem ORT...
David Boder: Hm.
Jacob Wilf: . . . haben wir eine der besten Weberschulen...Weberschule in Bielsk.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Wilf: Nicht weit von Katowitz.
Jacob Wilf: Dort haben wir heute dreißig Jugendliche.
David Boder: Männer oder Frauen?
Jacob Wilf: Hauptsächlich Männer, alle haben dort ein „bursa“. Dort leben sie, bekommen ihren ganzen Aushalt und lernen.
David Boder: Was nennt man ein „bursa“?
Jacob Wilf: Das ist ein Haus, wo sie wohnen und bekommen den Unterhalt.
David Boder: Warum nennt man es „bursa“?
Jacob Wilf: Das ist ein polnischer Name.
David Boder: Ah, polnisch, ja. Nun?
Jacob Wilf: Ausserdem sind geschaffen worden ein zweites Zentrum in Oberschlesien—in Bytom, ist geschaffen worden eine Schlosser und mechanische Schule. Wir haben bekommen auch ein speziell „binion“, es wurde repariert und in den nächsten Tagen fängt die richtige Arbeit an.
David Boder: Was ist ein „binion“?
Jacob Wilf: Ein Gebäude.
David Boder: Ein Gebäude. Nun als...das ist die...so wie geht es im Allgemeinen?
Jacob Wilf: Die Juden in Polen haben alle Möglichkeiten sich selber anzupassen, es ist zum ersten Mal so in der Geschichte von Polen, dass sind die Juden geworden gleichberechtigte Bürger, faktisch, juridisch und wirtschaftlich. Die Versuche zur „Aktion“...zu machen ein jüdisches Problem in Polen werden doch entscheidend zurück gewiesen von der ganz demokratischen polnischen Bevölkerung.
David Boder: Oh.
Jacob Wilf: Nur die Kraft der „Aktion“...
David Boder: Was ist die „Aktion“?
Jacob Wilf: Die Reaktion.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Wilf: Das sind die polnischen Faschisten...
Jacob Wilf: . . . die schon in der Regierung waren bis neunzehn hundert neun und dreißig (1939), weil die haben in dem Moment verloren die Macht von ihre Hände. Die wollen die Macht nicht völlig [unverständlich], obwohl sie wissen, dass sie die Macht nicht mehr bekommen, hier und im Ausland erschweren sie die neue demokratische Regierung, sie schaffen Unruhe bei der Bildung und dem Aufbau eines neuen Polens. Eine der Methoden mit welcher sie führen die Reaktion—die Faschisten...die polnischen Faschisten führen den Kampf gegen die Regierung, ist die Aktion—die Kämpfe gegen Juden. Deswegen ist das Ergebnis davon gewesen das Pogrom in Kielce...
David Boder: Erzählen Sie mir von dem Pogrom mit alle Einzelheiten, die Sie wissen?
Jacob Wilf: Das Pogrom ist heraus gegeben worden von den ausgehenden Nachforschungen von den Sich...Sicherheitsorganen, welche wir hier haben und war inspiriert von den polnischen, ausländischen Agenten.
David Boder: Polnisch?
Jacob Wilf: Polnische, ausländische Agenten.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Wilf: Unmittelbar direkt daraus ist die Provokation geworden, war der Grund von dem, dass man hat beschuldigt, dass ein polnisches Kind die Juden haben geschnappt um von ihm Blut abzunehmen, aber es ist ihnen gelungen das Kind zu retten.
David Boder: Ja, aber sagen Sie mir, was hat man gesagt, für was haben die Juden gebraucht das Blut?
Jacob Wilf: Nun das ist die alte Verleumdung, man glaubt, dass die Juden zum Bar mitzven für rituale Zwecke brauchen Blut von christliche Kinder.
David Boder: Nun ist da noch gewesen eine andere Verleumdung?
Jacob Wilf: Nein, in diesem Fall war es die Einzige.
David Boder: Das ist ein Altweibermärchen. Also ich habe gehört eine andere Geschichte, aber Sie sagen es „this way“. Also, das ist interessant. Sie brauchen das Blut? Das ist doch gewesen im Juli, „the Pogrom“.
Jacob Wilf: Ja.
David Boder: Wer kommt jetzt zum Pesa?
Jacob Wilf: Nein. Das ist der...das ist die Behauptung, dass die Juden bar-mitzven zu verschiedene andere Rituale...
David Boder: Oh...
Jacob Wilf: . . . man darf nicht Blut von christliche Kinder.
David Boder: Nicht nur für Mazos?
Jacob Wilf: Nicht nur für Matze. Und das Kind ist herum gegangen. Es war gewesen angestichelt von den Agenten. Und das Kind ist herum gegangen und hat gesagt, dass es ist gewesen gehalten bei Juden im Keller zwei Tag...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Wilf: . . . und erst danach ist ihm gelungen heraus zu kommen.
David Boder: Hat er gesagt, da waren andere Kind oder nein?
Jacob Wilf: Nein, nur für sich allein.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Wilf: Erst danach, hat man gemacht eine Nachforschung und da hat sich heraus gewiesen, dass das Kind war angestiftet—der eigene Vater hat das Kind gehalten und hat ihm eingeredet diese Verleumdung zu machen. Haben die Polen auch gehabt, die Masse ist gewesen...die haben dahin geschickt Agenten—Einer hat schon in der Früh...
David Boder: Herüber geschickt Agenten?
Jacob Wilf: Herüber geschickt vom Ausland Agenten...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Wilf: Und schon am früh haben sich zusammen Massen. Man hat von Mund zu Mund übergegeben die Version und so hat man angefangen heraus zu schleppen Juden von dem Haus, wo ist gewesen das jüdische Kommittee In Kielce.
Jacob Wilf: Ausserdem hat man geschnappt die Juden auf der Gasse. Der Pogrom hat gedauert fast einen ganzen Tag. Die [unverständlich] das hat sich heraus gewiesen, aber die Funktionäre von der Miliz...
David Boder: Hm.
Jacob Wilf: . . . haben auch mitgemacht in der Aktion.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Wilf: Zum Ende von dem Tag mit Hilfe von den Sicherheitsorganen und dem polnischen Militär ist es gelungen das Pogrom zu liquidieren.
David Boder: Was war der Name von dem, hm, Präsident...der jüdischen, hm, Ge...
Jacob Wilf: Der Vorsitzende von dem jüdischen Kommittee, der auch ermordet wurde auf schändliche Art an dem Tag, ist gewesen Doktor Kahane.
David Boder: Kahane?
Jacob Wilf: Kahane.
David Boder: Hm.
Jacob Wilf: Erst nachdem, wenn man [unverständlich] Ausforschung—eine spezielle Kommission angekommen ist in Warschau und die mit allen Mitteln verschaffen Sicherheit für die Juden, welche sind noch geblieben. In spezielle Autos sind sie heraus geführt worden nach Lodz.
David Boder: Diese von Kielce?
Jacob Wilf: Diese von Kielce. Und schon nach ein paar Tagen, um zu überzeugen die polnischen Massen—die starke Hand von der polnischen Regierung in starker Reaktion gegen die Fälle ist gewesen der Prozess gegen die Hauptanstifter von dem Pogrom in nur ein paar Tagen und innerhalb von zehn (10) Tage sind neun Polakken zu Tode verurteilt und in vier (4) Tagen danach ist das Todesurteil ausgeführt worden.
David Boder: So denkt ihr, dass die Sachen von Pogrom helfen, die Sachen auch so ein bisschen zu stillen, damit sich [unverständlich] die Bevölkerung.
Jacob Wilf: Die Situation ist folgendermaßen hier, dank der starken Hand von der polnischen Regierung, die so scharf reagiert hat auf das Kielcer Pogrom, hat sich daraus starke Beruhigung im Land entwickelt, desto mehr da die Arbeitermassen, die polnischen Massen haben in allen Städte gehalten spezielle Meetings und haben mobilisiert die polnischen Massen gegen den Kampf für die Faschisten, die polnischen Faschisten. Die Arbeiter haben...die polnischen Arbeiter haben auf die Meetings heraus gewesen [unverständlich] dem polnischen Volk, dass die Pogrome schaden nicht nur wenn gewendet gegen Juden; also die Hand, welche schlägt die polnischen...die Demokraten, die Intervent Hand, die kämpft gegen die polnische Regierung, die bewirkt daraus spezielle Pogrome—diese schaden der polnischen Regierung im Ausland, um daraus zu rufen Unruhe im Land. Und der Effekt ist schon der, dass in der letzten Zeit ist gewesen eine starke Beruhigung insofern desto mehr muss die Regierung alle Schutzmittel dagegen anwenden, dass sich solche Geschehen nicht wiederholen. Eines dieser Schutzmittel ist, dass die polnische Regierung hat gegeben spezielle Verhütungsmittel an alle jüdischen Kommitäten...an alle jüdischen Institutionen und sie werden speziell bewacht von den Sicherheitsorganen. Und deswegen hoffen wir, dass sich das nicht wiederholen muss, was vorher vorgekommen ist.
David Boder: Haben sie erlaubt die Juden sollen Waffen haben?
Jacob Wilf: Alle Juden, die arbeiten beim jüdischen Kommittee und haben Verantwortungsposten...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Wilf: . . . haben das Recht und haben Bewaffnungsmittel und Erlaubnis zu tragen bei sich die Bewaffnung.
David Boder: Nun sag mir, aber man sieht jetzt hier in Paris wieder sehr viele Juden, was kommen gelaufen von Polen die letzten...hm, vier Wochen.
Jacob Wilf: Ja, im Zusammenhang mit den Kielcer Pogromen ist klar, dass ist entstanden eine Psychose zwischen die jüdischen Massen. In...es ist gewesen eine Zeit—einige Wochen nach die Kielcer Pogrome, wo grössere Gruppen von verschiedenen Teilen von Polen sind dann heraus gefahren, [unverständlich] zu retten das Leben. Nun wir müssen sagen nach den objektiven Bedingungen, die schafften die Unruhestimmung bei den Juden in Polen, sind gewesen andere Faktoren, die schon geschaffen die Alarmstimmung. Verantwortliche [unverständlich] haben ausgenützt die...die
David Boder: Verantwortliche was?
Jacob Wilf: [unverständlich] Gesellschaftliche Verantwortliche haben ausgenützt die Verhältnisse, die objektiven Bedingungen,die Unruhestimmung, die entstanden ist durch die Kielcer Pogrome—und haben begonnen eine spezielle Propaganda—aber die Unruhestimmung war stark und deswegen die Juden kommen raus. Ein Fakt...
David Boder: . . . so dass die Juden heraus gehen sollen?
Jacob Wilf: ..... . so dass die Juden kommen raus; ungeachtet dass in dem Moment keine Emigrationsmöglichkeiten für Juden nicht gegeben hat. Es ist klar, dass jeder Jud, der hat Emigrationsmöglichkeiten, es ist klar und es ist gerechtfertigt und er muss raus. Auf dem Standpunkt stehen auch die Vorsteher von der polnischen Regierung, weil sie haben gegeben ein Erklärung, dass sie werden unterstützen Emigrationsbestreben von die Juden in legale Formen. Dagegen ist aber die polnische Regierung im Interesse der jüdischen Massen gegen Unruhestimmungen in jedem wo Juden sind chaotisch, ohne Ziel, in unlegalen Emigrationsmöglichkeiten heraus wandern. Wir haben hier eine Situatio, die soll anspornen die Leut , die eben haben Brüder und in dem Moment...die sind von Polen...sind in deutsche Lager unter englischer oder amerikanischer Okkupation. Also so hat sich letzthin die Situation in Polen beruhigt. [unverständlich] eine jüdische Gemeinschaft in Polen...
David Boder: Eine jüdische was?
Jacob Wilf: Eine jüdische Wirtschaft, eine jüdische Gesellschaft, eine jüdische Gemeinschaft.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Wilf: . . . von den jüdischen Massen in Polen. Eine Gemeinschaft von hundert vierzig tausend (140,000) Juden muss haben den größten Willen zu bleiben in Polen, die auch haben verantwortliche, wirtschaftliche Regierungsposten. Alle...
David Boder: Hat die polnische Regierung Juden in der Regierung?
Jacob Wilf: Die polnische Regierung wünschen...wünschen Richtung zu geben jedem Jud, was hat die entsprechende Qualifikationen und will arbeiten und will unternehmen ein Regierungsposten, wird die Möglichkeit geben und zu nehmen, die größten Regierungsposten, wenn man hat die entsprechenden Qualifikationen. Das ist, dass wir haben in der polnischen Regierung verantwortliche Staatsmänner, wir haben Juden, die übernehmen verantwortliche Regierungsposten ungeachtet, dass sie sind Juden. Unsere Männer haben die Posten, weil sie auch haben die entsprechende Qualifikationen. Ausserdem ist in letzter Zeit gelungen dem jüdischen Kommittee anzuordnen die Juden in der Schwerindustrie. In den Kohlengruben—wir haben heutzutage viele Arbeiter, was arbeiten unter der Erd als Schachtarbeiter...
David Boder: Jüdische?
Jacob Wilf: Jüdische...in Oberschlesien und Niederschlesien. Und alle die Juden—speziell die, die sind eingeordnet in der Industrie, die sich vernehmen mit produktiver Arbeit—haben das Verlangen zu verbleiben in Polen, weil sie sehen, dass die polnische demokratische Regierung nun ist gegeben ein Verbündeten, wo es gibt jede Garantie, dass sie sich können ausleben national sowie sozial. Wir Juden in Polen geben sich die Idee, dass alle jüdischen Volk—das Ziel des jüdischen Volkes ist verbunden mit der Verstärkung der Demokratie der ganzen Welt. Wenn sich verstärkt, wenn die Demokratie auf der ganzen Welt offen wird, hoffen wir, dass dann morgen ein bessere und eine glücklichere Zeit wird, nicht wie heut. Wir Juden in Polen, wir nehmen einen aktiven Anteil in der Verstärkung, in dem Aufbau der Demokratie in Polen, weil wir glauben, das ist eine der wichtigsten Etappen für die Verstärkung der Demokratie in der ganzen Welt. Wir verbinden unser Ziel mit dem Sieg der Demokratie in Polen. Und so, weil wir glauben, es wird siegen die Demokratie auf der ganzen Welt, so sind wir sicher es wird siegen die Demokratie in Polen und darin liegen alle ökonomischen und objektiven Bedingungen für den Wiederaufbau einer neuen, gesunden jüdischen Gemeinschaft in Polen.
David Boder: Nun sag mir, wieviel Juden sind in Polen geblieben?
Jacob Wilf: Heutzutage haben wir mehr als hundert dreißig bis hundert vierzig tausend Juden in Polen.
David Boder: Das ist alles was ist geblieben von die Juden in Polen?
Jacob Wilf: Das ist gewesen nachdem die Juden schon haben verlassen Polen...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Wilf: . . . in verschiedene Länder.
David Boder: Wie viele...wie viele schätzt ihr sind ausgewandert?
Jacob Wilf: Wir haben herausgefunden, dass in der Zeit der Repatriierung...in der Zeit von einem Jahr die Zahl der Juden, die sind heraus gefahren war nahezu hundert tausend Juden.
David Boder: Also alles zusammen—wieviel Juden sind gewesen in Polen bevor dem Krieg?
Jacob Wilf: Vor dem Krieg sind wir gewesen drei ein halb ( 3 ½ )Millionen Juden in Polen.
David Boder: Das ist alles?
Jacob Wilf: Das ist gewesen die jüdische Bevölkerung in Polen.
David Boder: Und was ist gewesen die polnische Population?
Jacob Wilf: Bitte?
David Boder: Und Polens?
Jacob Wilf: Die ganze Bevölkerung on Polen ist gewesen ungefähr dreißig (30) Millionen.
David Boder: So die Juden sind gewesen zwölf (12) Prozent.
Jacob Wilf: Ja.
David Boder: All right! Und jetzt—was ist die polnische Bevölkerung jetzt nach Ihrer Berechnung?
Jacob Wilf: Nach neuer Berechnung zwei und zwanzig (22) Millionen.
David Boder: Hm, warum?
Jacob Wilf: Weil der Rest in Poland ist ausgerottet worden und ein Teil der Emigranten befindet sich noch außerhalb des Landes.
David Boder: Ja. Und dann ein Teil von Polen ist gegangen zu Russland, nicht wahr?
Jacob Wilf: Ja. Die haben aber auf Grund einer Abmachung zwischen Russland und Polen...haben sie sich repatriiert zurück in die Gebiete, welches wir haben als das jetzige Polen.
David Boder: Ach so jetzt mit zwei und zwanzig (22) Millionen polnische Population...
Jacob Wilf: Ja.
David Boder: . . . und ungefähr hundert fünfzig tausend (150 000) Juden...
David Boder: . . . die...die Bevölkerung von die Juden weniger als ein Perzent.
Jacob Wilf: Ja.
David Boder: Also das ist geblieben von die ganzen Juden in Polen?
Jacob Wilf: Bis lang sind geblieben Juden...perzentuell zwei (2) Prozent sind die früheren jüdischen [unverständlich]...
David Boder: Und sie sagen...
Jacob Wilf: Acht und neunzig (98) Prozent der polnischen Juden, die die sind gewesen im Land während der Okkupation...aber nicht gezählt, die sind gewesen im Ausland.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Wilf: Acht und neunzig Perzent der polnischen Juden, wo sind gewesen während der Okkupation sind vernichtet worden. Der Rest hat sich gerettet auf sogenannte arische, christliche Papiere...
Jacob Wilf: Die haben sich gerettet mit diesen Papieren.
David Boder: Nun also Mr. Wilf, das ist ein sehr interessanter Standpunkt. Es ist natürlich...nun was denkt ihr wird sein die beste Lösung für die Frage von die Juden, die nun sind in deutschen Lagern hier in Frankreich? Zum Beispiel, letzte Woche ist von Lodz eine ganze Delegation von Yeshiva gekommen und es werden noch kommen mehr von dort. Also was denken Sie, was soll man tun mit alle diese Menschen?
Jacob Wilf: Das ist eben die nicht-richtige Stellung der gesellschaftlichen [unverständlich]. Mir ist es klar, dass es Juden in Poland gibt, die zu ihren Verwanden emigrieren wollen oder weil er noch aus irgend einem ideologischen Standpunkt will fahren nach Israel...es ist klar, dass man darf diesen Menschen geben die Möglichkeit. Aber die Gesellschaften, die sich befassen mit der Frage, sollen und dürfen in erster Reihe sicherstellen, dass Emigrationsmöglichkeiten—legale, menschliche Emigrationsmöglichkeiten bestehen und nicht heraus führen chaotisch die Juden von Polen. Desto mehr muss objektive Bedingungen, denn die sind nicht vorhanden. Rausführen aus den Lagern...in dem Moment befinden sich die Juden in den deutschen Lagern, so wie wir informiert sind, in sehr schweren ökonomischen Bedingungen und ausserdem fehlen einstweilen—in diesem Moment nicht vorhanden die legalen Möglichkeiten um heraus zu führen die Juden nach einem Land, wo sie können endlich finden ein Land, wo sie in Frieden leben können. Sie sitzen herum in den Lagern und warten, dass sie bekommen Auswanderungszertifikate für Israel oder Einreisegenehmigungen in andere Länder. Es ist klar, das diese Situation—das Liquidieren der Lager von die Juden in Deutschland—wir dauern nicht weniger wie zwei (2) Jahr. Und so leiden die Juden noch zwei (2) Jahre—das Leben von die Juden in die Lager...es ist klar, es ist sehr schwer.
David Boder: Wollen Sie das wirklich unternehmen zu sagen den polnischen Juden, die jetzt sitzen in Deutschland oder Frankreich, dass es sicher ist für sie zurück zu kommen nach Polen?
Jacob Wilf: Wir haben schon Fälle in dem Moment...aber es sind einzelne Fälle...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Wilf: Sehr wenige Fälle, aber es sind Fälle, wo die Juden kommen zurück nach Polen. Weil, wie ich hab schon gesagt, wenn es Juden gibt, die denken, dass es gibt keine Sicherheit zu leben in Polen oder will vielleicht aus anderen Gründen heraus fahren, es ist klar, dass wegen solchen Gründen sie eine Chance haben weg zu gehen. Weil die polnische Regierung stellt nicht Sperrungen für die Ausfuhr. Aber das ist klar, da es nicht gibt objektive Bedingungen statt zu wohnen in die Lager in Deutschland, das ist klar, dass es wäre rationeller, logischer zu bleiben in Polen, als zu verbinden mit seinen Verwandten in Amerika, in Kanada und in andere Länder—als zu bekommen Einreisebewilligungen und direkt zu kommen nach Polen direkt zu die Verwanden und nicht durch zu machen diese schrecklichsten Etappen wie sie sich stellen vor die Lager in Deutschland.
David Boder: Nun...gibt es noch welche andere Punkte, die Sie wollen beschreiben? Sie sagen dass sich die Juden beteiligen an andere Sachen. Sind die jüdischen Professoren zurück gekommen zur Universität von Warschau oder zu den anderen Universitäten?
Jacob Wilf: Was angeht die jüdische Intelligenz in Polen...die meisten sind vernichtet worden während der Okkupation. Aber die, die sich noch waren in Polen, die arbeiten weiter bei ihren früherigen Posten.
David Boder: Wollen Sie noch über etwas reden, wollen Sie etwas klären? Über die ganze Situation...wollen Sie noch etwas hinzufügen?
Jacob Wilf: Ich wollte nur noch das bemerken, dass wir, die Juden in Polen, die jüdischen Kommittees in Polen, sind letzthin nicht nur aktiv selbst hier nicht nur zu den großen Hilfsaktivitäten, aber darauf, dass jeder Jud sein vormalige Arbeitsstätte aufbaut...und zu schaffen alle Bedingungen, dass die Juden sollen arbeiten produktiv, dass sie auch wieder aufbauen das jüdische Leben in Polen...und auch wiederum aufbauen die jüdische Gemeinschaft in Polen. Heutzutage werden geschaffen jüdische Kulturinstitute in Polen. Wir haben jetzt in Polen einen jüdischen Rassenverband, wir haben zwei jüdische Theater, um aufzubauen das kulturelle Leben. Wir haben das Bestreben dass diese kleine jüdische Gemeinschaft sodann wieder ein Kern der jüdischen Gesellschaft bekomme, wie vor dem Krieg und wir haben das Bestreben, dass die jüdische Yishuv in Polen...
David Boder: Was ist jüdische Yishuv?
Jacob Wilf: Die jüdische Gesellschaft in Polen...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Wilf: . . . so wie sie haben genommen einen aktiven Anteil während der Kriegszeit mit den deutschen Verband—dann wie die Juden haben genommen einen aktiven Anteil auf der Front, entweder war es auf der Front oder mit den Partisanen oder in der Vorbereitung eines Aufstandes. So sind wir auch heute...die Juden in Polen nehmen einen aktiven Anteil in dem Aufbau der neuen polnischen Miliz basierend auf dem neuen demokratischen Prinzip. Wir wollen [unverständlich] den Preußen in der Verstärkung der Demokratie.
David Boder: Nun sag mir dies...etwas über Russland. Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie haben gearbeitet als Advokat. Haben die Russen erlaubt, dass sie privat praktizieren...privat als Advokat? Und haben sie auch privat bekommen bezahlt von dem Menschen für Ihre Arbeit?
Jacob Wilf: Die Advokatur in Russland ist eine Kooperative...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Wilf: . . . eine Kollektive.
Jacob Wilf: Jeder muss eine entsprechende Qualifikation haben, dann tritt er in eine Kollektive ein in der entsprechenden Stadt und ist dann ein Mitglied der juristischen Gruppierung...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Wilf: . . . was gibt juristische Arbeit der Bevölkerung—tritt auf in Gerichte und handelt alle jüdischen Probleme...alle juristischen Probleme.
David Boder: Juristisch.
Jacob Wilf: Der Lohn der Advokaten in Russland ist ein Prozent von dem was die Klienten haben zu zahlen an...
David Boder: . . . an die Kooperative.
Jacob Wilf: . . . an die Kooperative.
David Boder: Oh. Kann der Klient wählen welchen Advokaten er will?
Jacob Wilf: Der Klient kommt in die Kooperative...in die Juristische und verlangt den oder jenen Advokat.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Wilf: Also so haben die Advokaten, die...sagen wir haben einen grösseren juristischen Einfluss, grössere juristische Fähigkeiten...
Jacob Wilf: . . . Bildung...
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Wilf: . . . haben das Recht vielleicht mehr auszulegen sich und haben auch eine grössere juristische Praxis als andere Advokaten, die einen schwächeren [unverständlich] .
David Boder: Können Sie mir erzählen über einen interessanten Prozess, den Sie haben gehabt während der ganzen Zeit in ihrer Praxis?
Jacob Wilf: In der Zeit wenn ich bin gewesen in Russland, habe ich Anteil genommen sehr oft—und trotzdem, dass ich bin gekommen von Polen—so in der Zeit hab ich gearbeitet...bin ich gewesen zugelassen zu die Prozesse gegen die, was haben oft gegen [unverständlich] und entgegen der russischen Regierung.
David Boder: Aha.
Jacob Wilf: Das waren die sogenannten konterrevolutionären Prozesse.
David Boder: Ja.
Jacob Wilf: Und ich musste feststellen als Advokat [unverständlich] Leute Anteil genommen in diese gewissen konterrevolutionären Prozesse.
David Boder: Sie haben sie verteidigt?
Jacob Wilf: Ich habe sie verteidigt. Die Regierung, die Sowjet Regierung gibt jedem, der angeklagt wird, das ist schon festgelegt in der Konstitution, das Recht zu haben einen Verteidiger. Er hat das Recht sich zu wählen den Verteidiger und wenn er hat nicht einen Verteidiger, dann bestimmt ihn die Regierung. Und es ist sehr oft vorgekommen, dass ich hatte die Möglichkeit zu vertreten solche konterrevolutionäre Verbrechen und ich musste feststellen, dass die haben gehabt alle Rechte zur Verteidigung genau wie in allen anderen Ländern.
David Boder: Haben sie jemals gewonnen so einen Fall?
Jacob Wilf: Es sind gewesen Fälle, wo die sind gewesen angeklagt...Bürger, sowjetische Bürger, auch polnische Bürger...für konterrevolutionäre Agitation und Propaganda. In der Konsequenz—in dem Prozess hat sich heraus gewiesen sehr oft, dass die Zeugenaussagen sind gewesen nicht richtig und es sind oft gewesen Fälle, wo man die Menschen frei gelassen hat.
David Boder: Das war nicht ein militärisches Gericht?
Jacob Wilf: Nein, es sind spezielle allgemeine Gerichte, die beurteilen alle anderen Prozesse. Die entscheiden aber auch die Prozesse der konterrevolutionären Aktivitäten.
David Boder: Haben sie Geschworene? [unverständlich; russisch]
Jacob Wilf: Dort in Russland ist es festgelegt, dass da ist ein Vorsitzender, der ist gewählt und ausserdem für die Leute ein [unverständlich].
David Boder: Wie viele?
Jacob Wilf: Zwei (2).
David Boder: [unverständlich; Tonband sehr schlecht und leise] das Gericht?
Jacob Wilf: Ja.
David Boder: Danke sehr, Mr. Wilf. Das war ein spezieller Report—eine spezielle...[Tonband endet]